how are you doing I'm you know actually
it's really nice to be doing something
vaguely professional and to be able to
publicize a film that brings a little
bubbler joy for a couple of hours to
people in these pretty hideous times I
can share that feeling right now so I
know you have a good deal of animation
experience but this particular role does
seem like one of the bigger kookier
roles you've played animation wise so
what is the key to make you feel
comfortable in the booths to just go
crazy with it
oh well it was Tony Tony the writer
director who just has the most
infectious laugh and for the task I know
it was true for everybody else's can you
tell the story in a way that seemed
vaguely honest but make Tony giggle so
that the take is unusable that was the
challenge and he encouraged me to go
over the top and then over the top of
that and then climb on top of that and
you know it's Dick Dastardly he is the
original mustache twirling villain so if
you're not gonna have fun doing him
where are you what is it like taking and
I kind of character like this but also
bringing your own voice to them is it a
situation where you are trying to pay
homage to what existed before or where
you could find a balance between
infusing yourself into it well the thing
about dick dusty in the cartoons in the
kind of ten minutes at a morning
cartoons or isalus at the morning is
that he's a pathetic and tragic loser
and one of a big cast of wacky racers
and when you're in a movie you want the
audience to have a big emotional
experience this film was about
friendship and loyalty and many things
like that and so he had to be not quite
as pathetic and not quite as much of a
loser because you need to be fearful of
it he's got to bribe some peril
luckily they drew him it's big muscly up
a box waiting for this can I lean
slightly hunched fool to come along and
if you look at any of the cartoons he's
got this kind of high wheezy voice
somewhat akin to Muttley and we gave him
a bit more meat on his bones so there's
you know we're paying homage in a
spiritual sense but you've also got to
just forget all that and create
something fresh and new that works for
this story speaking of the look of the
character I feel like if they ever did a
live-action version you could pull it
off but
you had the opportunity to pick any of
your animated characters and play them
in a live-action feature who would you
pick and why well I did Superman in
Superman under the red Sun which who
wouldn't want to fly although I suspect
it's not actually that comfortable
having watched them all do Quidditch
balancing on broomsticks I played Satan
lot sometimes I was in a Pixar film
being a plane that might be fun but I
was back to flying again you know I've
done so many animated I was in a habit
ah the series of Avatar oh I knew I'd be
I'd be the Inquisitor Star Wars right is
the right answer because he has the
coolest lightsaber in the entire Star
Wars universe the entire time yeah so in
honor of Shaggy and Scooby what is the
most outrageous ridiculous meal you like
to make Oh God but I take a lot of
things that don't belong together mostly
that have sugar fat and chocolate in
them and I melt them together and I make
sure that no one is going to see and I
eat though and sometimes throw a banana
in so I can pull myself there is a
health component ice cream chocolate
marshmallows it really doesn't matter if
it once had fat and sugar I'll eat it
yes great minds right here thank you so
much for your time and congratulations
from the movie thanks very much I've
ever enjoyed the film